and the Oscar goes to Bob Dylan
oh god this is amazing
oh god I think Curtis Hanson for
encouraging me to do this song and
everybody at Paramount
sherry lags and Jonathan doujin but
especially Curtis who just kept at it
and instead this song was right and just
encouraged me to do it so much and I'm
so glad I did everybody at cambia
records Brooke my record company who
supports me all through these years time
Mottola dhania Erler Jenkins will Botwin
Jonna gracias everybody like that up
there I want to say over my all my
family and friends out there watching
and I want to thank the members of the
Academy who who were bold enough to to
give me this award for this song which
obviously a song that doesn't pussyfoot
around or turn a blind eye to human
nature and God bless you all with peace
tranquility and goodwill Thanks
here's some dip thank you
by the way it was great seeing Bob Dylan
live from Australia which has an 18 hour
time difference which to bob is normal
and by the way be sure to stay tuned
throughout the whole show because at the
end of the night we're going to vote
someone out of show business